[Music]
in the year
10191 the pattershaw emperor rules the
known universe however he is merely a
puppet of the religious order known as
the benny jesseret and the navigator's
guild their survival depends on control
of the spice melange a substance that
unlocks the potential for eternal life
and faster than light travel but the
spice can only be found on the planet
arrakis a desert world under the control
of the great house harkonnen
oh i'm not finished there's still way
more exhibition to get through believe
me
house arkhonen and the rivals of the
great house atreides led by duke leto a
leader with popular support and acclaim
to the throne sensing a threat the
emperor lures house atreides to arrakis
also known as dune and plots with their
rivals to quietly eliminate them but
what they can't foresee is an alliance
between duke lido's son paula tradies
and the frimen a planet-wide collective
of desert nomads who've learned to
survive the harsh environment including
the sand worms hey i said it wasn't
finished yet do you want to know what
the quit satch head rack is or not okay
fine dude
witness the film david lynch chose to
direct instead of return of the jedi and
like can you even imagine
in this two hour long speed run through
frank herbert's 500 page epic damn
sloppy really damn sloppy it's delivered
mostly through asmr whispering here it
comes yes
perhaps you would do that tonight
i may lose my son
what does she fear some strength
i must not fear pure
unrefined spice there's the imperial
conditioning assurance of trust i must
warn you you are in great danger i've
tried to take the life of my son oh
still
this sucks
timothy chalamet looks cute as paul but
he's merely hair to the throne of kyle
mclaughlin this well-conditioned teen
suffering from a case of old face is
still an expert in minecraft fighting
shoot charlie
[Music]
and using his big boy voice you mustn't
speak
in the book read in horror as paul's mom
tricks a native people into making him
their messiah but in the film watch in
horror as they ditch that subplot so now
paul just kinda is the white space jesus
one cannot go against the word of god in
this story that compresses all the
fighting and romance into a single
montage in the two standard years that
followed paul and johnny's love grew to
make room for more drugged outrage dudes
gone off that space crack it is by the
juice of saffoo that thoughts acquire
speed the lips require stains stains
become a warning it is by will alone i
set my mind in motion you know the
secret to micro dosing is taking micro
doses my guy
[Music]
track dozens of characters whose names
sound like sneezes and or typos
rather but if you ever get lost use
cinema's oldest trick to help you tell
the good guys from the bad hot thin
straight good gross fat gay bad ginger
even worse and no one is more ginger
than baron harkonnen david lynch will
sear this pus-filled face into your
memory whether he's slathering himself
in bug juice or deflowering this flower
boy he's the most disturbing thing in
the film since the toothy pink face of
the sand worms or the smoky vag mouth of
the navigators or a greased up sting in
a leather mankini
did someone call the police the boner
police
experience a film that definitely would
have launched a snyder cut style
campaign if used net forms had more sway
back then that put a beloved nerd story
in an auteur's hands then ripped it away
and turned his five-hour cut into a
two-hour train wreck giving final
directing credit on some cuts to someone
named alan smithy and if you haven't
seen alan smithy's other work i mean wow
who is this joker how can one director
be so bad in so many different styles
who keeps hiring this guy
so suit up in a suit that you can poop
and pee in to make it through this
cursed production that followed another
cursed dune production but it led to
denise villanue getting to do what he
does best hundred million dollar budget
updates to sci-fi flops from the 80s ooh
do the hidden next you can even keep
comic mclaughlin
[Music]
starring
starship coopers
eric leto
the spice girls chickadee
dirty hollow deck
idaho no unibrow
murder in a speedo and this is a free
willy
dune worms my car
why is kyle mclaughlin so wooden in this
we know he's got the energy but man
being attacked by electric eels
please say in your honest voice
no matter how bad life gets there's
always beer
i fart in your general direction your
mother was a hamster and your father
smelled of elderberries
you're killing me larry